with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
tools for migrating your databases to
Google cloud then stay tuned because
here's the rewind in this session learn
about the options to migrate your creat
workloads to Google cloud platform in
ways that you can minimize the
disruption that our migration can cause
you will learn about three steps for
migration first is the assessment to
figure out what to move and if it is
ready to be moved as well to learn about
the new path to the cloud and how the
support for that workload would be
second is the migration itself if this
will be a simple real host or completely
rewrite it will depend on your needs and
third is attaining an optimization part
how do I get better faster and cheaper
to help with all of those steps we have
migration partners which we showcased in
this session to help you achieve either
your homogeneous migration for instance
my SQL to cut sequel or HBase to cut
BigTable or if it is a heterogeneous
migration like Oracle 2 called sequel
Postgres the session also shows how a
migration to called Seco can be done by
yourself and this could happen mainly in
two ways a simple approach or a minimum
downtime approach if you can afford
downtime and this won't affect your
business you can go through the simple
route by doing an offline migration
where you get all your data into a dump
file and import into a new cloud sequel
instance all this phase is completed
then you can put all systems online
again if your application cannot take a
significant downtime then another
solution that we have is using call Seco
as an external replica to your primary
server the way this works
is by spinning up a new instance on
called Seco using a migrate data option
and reference your primary server that
way replication will start and catch up
meaning that every change you made in
your previous server will be applied to
the new one on Google cloud platform
also replication cuts up it is time to
do the work of stopping replication
promoting your replicas to primary and
making sure your applications aware of
the new server to be able to do reads
and writes on the new called Seco
instance the effective time taking on
this model will depend on a few
variables that the session explains such
as DNS propagation if you'd like to see
the full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
describe to the cloud youtube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]